united states senator ted cruz bought
the bitcoin dip that's right ted cruz
watching bitcoin falling all the way
down into the mid 30 thousand dollar
price point and he decided to scoop some
up for himself in a recent financial
disclosure at the end of january ted
cruz disclosed that he went ahead and he
bought somewhere between fifteen
thousand and fifty thousand dollars
worth of bitcoin at the time bitcoin was
trading somewhere between thirty six or
thirty seven thousand dollars here's the
exact transaction and of course this is
part of the beauty of these financial
disclosures is we know what politicians
are buying and how much and exactly when
they're doing it now that ted cruz is
buying bitcoin we shouldn't be surprised
he's been very very bullish on texas
becoming the hub of bitcoin mining we
know that texas now has about 10
of the bitcoin hash rate globally he's
also in a very very intelligent move
advocated for crypto payments at the
gift shops and vending machines around
the us capital complex his thought
process was if politicians are going to
regulate this stuff maybe they should
use it maybe they should understand how
exactly it works but ted cruz is not the
only politician that owns bitcoin we go
and we look at other financial
disclosures cynthia alumnus of wyoming
jake austin loss of massachusetts marie
newman of illinois jeff van der drew of
new jersey and barrymore of alabama all
also owning bitcoin as well and so when
we start to think about this there are
politicians both in the senate and
congress that own bitcoin they are not
the first ones they will not be the last
ones ted cruz joining a line of other
politicians ultimately bitcoin is an
american technology it competes on a
global scale the decentralized digital
currency allows for censorship payments
and transactions bitcoin is as american
as apple pie and it's only fitting that
now the senator from texas he's got
bitcoin in his portfolio as well